tre région
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie est
libre en bourgogne et en franche comté
une émission grande région consacré
aujourd'hui à la politique régionale des
transports au lendemain du vote du
premier budget de la nouvelle assemblée
alors la part consacrée aux transports
représentent un quart du budget total
avec 315 millions d'euros pour parler de
tout cela autour de la table jérémy
chevreuil bonjour nous avons réuni
quatre invités bonjour eric bonjour à
tous ses invités je voulais présent
qu'il ya d'abord le monsieur transports
à la région
michel neugnot premiers 10 président
socialiste du conseil régional
vous êtes en charge des transports au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté à l'association des régions de
france et vous venez d'être nommé au
conseil d'administration de sncf réseau
également sur ce plateau à représentants
des usagers à des transports la fnaut de
bourgogne vous cédric journaux en est le
président il représente donc les usagers
et puis deux élus des groupes
d'opposition au conseil régional
gérald gordat conseiller régional l'est
républicain et damien campa conseiller
régional front national bonjour à tous
les quatre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous le savez on perd pas nos bonnes
habitudes cette émission c est aussi la
vôtre vous pouvez y participer en
interpellant nos invités en leur posant
vos questions 100 sera le relais avec
eric tout au long de l'émission pour
poser vos questions c'est simple il
suffit de vous rendre sur les sites
internet de france 3 bourgogne et de
france 3 franche comté à la page de la
voie est libre
et puis vous pouvez commenter l'émission
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le modeste
qui s'affiche
lvl bfc comme la voix est libre
bourgogne franche comté
eric on commence ce débat en prenant à
prendre un peu de hauteur oui on va
commencer par les aéroports mais on
précise qu on a déjà reçu d'ailleurs
beaucoup beaucoup de questions preuve
qu'il ya beaucoup d'attentes alors on va
tenter de répondre à un maximum d'entre
elles alors donc les aéroports la
présidente de la région marie-guite
dufay a annoncé un audit en attendant
elle refuse de financer l'infrastructure
de dole tavaux
alors que devient à cet aéroport et bien
c'est la question que nous pose un
internaute spitfire qui s'inquiètent
après les suppressions des lignes vers
bordeaux nice et toulouse cet été alors
pour lancer le débat
je vous propose
écoutez la récente déclaration du
président du jura clément pernot
aujourd'hui non c'est l'ensemble des des
habitants de bourgogne franche comté qui
se servent de l'équipement 18% durassien
et il ya 25 % des gens du doubs 20 % des
gens de côte-d'or jambon bref c'est un
équipement largement partagée donc le
coût doit être partagée parce qu'il faut
préciser que l'aéroport de dole tavaux
et financé ce gisement par le conseil
départemental du jura
cent quarante mille voyageurs à l'an
dernier qui viennent de toute la région
comme le disait clément pernot
est ce que ça ne justifie pas un
cofinancement du conseil régional michel
neugnot les deux conseils régionaux ont
été très clairs dans le passé par
rapport aux low cost en disant que
c'était pas notre vocation à financer du
low cost
donc nous sommes sur ce point on peut
dire aussi pour continuer ce qu'elle
vient de dire le président du conseil
général clément pernot que vous avez
aussi une grande partie de voie de
passage et qui viennent de l'extérieur
d'abord franche comté donc ce que nous
voulons faire c'est mettre à plat
l'ensemble des structures aéroportuaires
de bourgogne franche comté
l'état des lieux est le suivant du som
dans trois syndicats mixtes auxerre
branche dijon longvic
et puis cinq ans est un aéroport dans le
change
gérald connais très bien où en forme
tous les pilotes
et puis il ya aussi d'autres aéroports
ou air qui fonctionne je pense à nevers
je pense chalon je pense besançon je
pense va donc une mise à plat définir
les besoins pour notre territoire
votre majorité était aux commandes des
deux conseils régionaux vous découvrez
la situation pour un besoin de faire un
audit sur l'ensemble des aéroports
mais on nous dit ça doit être partagée
c'est pas un audit c'est un état des
lieux mais vous ne me laissez la dame
était aux affaires
nous connaissons l'état des lieux et si
vous voulez je peux vous en parler très
longuement mais vous avez souhaité que
l'on fasse des réponses cours donc je
savais pas je vous donne l'objectif
l'objectif que nous avons est très clair
c'est d'avoir une stratégie
d'utilisation et de ses fonctionnalités
de ces différents aéroports que dans le
passé on opposer les uns aux autres il
faut le mettre dans la chaîne de
mobilité et notamment allant vers
l'extérieur les tgv en font partie aussi
donc on doit avoir un grand débat dans
cette région sur les fonctionnalités que
l'on veut est le meilleur outil pour
répondre aux besoins des usagers
c'est ça que nous faisons en place de
façon participative c'est la marque de
fabrique de cette région c'est dire on
est pas on n'est pas sur des débats
totalement désincarné hors sol nous
sommes par rapport à la complémentarité
de tous les moyens de transport
possibles sur le territoire qu'elles
soient en fonctionnalités dont nous
avons besoin
comment ils veulent quand on part
qualité mais en attendant ces aéroports
fonctionnent en erreur on y reviendra
agenda quelle est votre position vous
serez alors déjà fait que françois
sauvadet lui prenait effectivement bien
d'autres pour répondre à monsieur
guillaume on a déjà parlé que le début
du mandat
quand même hallucinant qu'on nous dise
aujourd'hui au mois de mai qu'on
réfléchisse qu'on essaye de voir qu'on
va consulter qu'on va dialoguer il ya
une campagne électorale qui a été longue
très longue trop longue pour certains on
a une présidente qui aujourd'hui a été
élu qui était présidente sortante d'une
partie de cette nouvelle région qui nous
a acquis a dit aux électeurs de cette
nouvelle région qu'elle avait l'avantagé
par rapport aux autres candidats d'être
en place et de bien connaître les
dossiers d'avoir travaillé depuis deux
ans et françois patriat et donc
indirectement admission deniau également
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à un
total amateurisme de dire aucune ligne
directrice et ça on le regrette
et là il ya quand même ligne directrice
c'est pas de low cost est ce que vous
vous inscrivez à cette position
justement premièrement je trouve que
c'est un très mauvais signal qui et pour
qui est envoyé aux compagnies aériennes
notamment que leur dire pour l'instant
on ne sait rien on attend qu'on fasse un
audit est une chose qu'on était de
réorganiser de et de rationaliser
l'action de la région en termes de dates
aéroportuaire je trouve que c'est une
bonne une bonne chose même si j'aurais
aimé que ça puisse être fait déjà avant
quant à la campagne électeurs donnait
déjà rire on est déjà réfléchi mais soit
l'audit est en route
nous attendrons la fin de deux enfants
du cadet les réponses qui seront
apportées pour pouvoir en débattre plus
longuement en tout cas ce qui concerne
le low cost
la question des lits n'est pas celle de
savoir s'il faut ou pas du low cost
la question est de savoir si on rend des
services aux habitants aujourd'hui les
habitants de bourgogne franche comté
sont nombreux et les habitants même de
l'extérieur de la région bourse comptait
sont très nombreux à utiliser les
services de l'aéroport à 135 mille
passagers je cours en 2015
donc c'est effectivement un sac adresses
avis rendu low cost ou pas pour moi la
question n'est pas là et puis en ce
temps terme en termes de stratégie la
deuxième partie qui devrait développer
c'est d'arriver à faire venir des
personnes de l'extérieur en bourgogne
franche comté et ça c'est vrai que un
aéroport qui est en développement et ça
fait que quatre ans que l'aéroport a
réellement pris son envol sans sans
mauvais jeu de mots on peut on peut
aujourd'hui on a une vrai intérêt
potentiel pour arriver à développer
l'attractivité notamment par le low cost
parce que ça servira aussi à ça et je
crois que notre rôle à nous c'est plutôt
plutôt garder posture idéologique c'est
plutôt d'être dans le rationnel pouvoir
utiliser l'équipement pour développer
gérald gordat vous parlez de la relance
de l'aéroport celui qui a relancé
l'aéroport c'est le socialiste
christophe perny quand il est arrivé à
la tête du département du jura
il n'est plus élu dans le jura
aujourd'hui mais il s'est exprimé sur le
sujet dans la presse écrite chez nos
confrères
cette semaine et ce qu'il dit est très
intéressant il estime que c'est une
erreur politique forte de la présidente
de la région si la région se retire dit
il il n'y a plus d'aéroport et puis il
détaille aussi que ryanair est selon lui
le socle de fonctionnement de l'aéroport
si ryanair s'en va les reports c'est
terminé
s'il ya plus de low cost il n'y a plus
d'aéroport
c'est un socialiste alors aujourd'hui je
suis radicaux de gauche mais il était
socialiste il ya encore quelques mois
qui répond et qui critiquent fermement
la position de la région de réponse
la première gérald gordat c'était dans
notre engagement de campagne de travail
et un modèle économique viable pour
l'ensemble des structures un reporter de
bourgogne franche comté
donc nous sommes dans cette logique nous
avons notre calendrier nous avons le
temps de la réflexion qu'elle nécessaire
et du partage de la situation
deuxièmement je dirais à monsieur permis
que si la région se retire la région n'a
jamais été dedans c'est que la région à
part vous serez b pendant très longtemps
dans un bar je suis vraiment content
pendant qu'on fait de façon plus
importante
le modèle économique est proposé
actuellement six républiques passagers
plus ça coûte en fonds publics
donc il faut travailler j'ai vu l'avion
j'ai vu le président de la cci à ce
sujet nous avons discuté lundi prenant
dans la grenade dans la gestion il est
totalement d'accord sur la façon dont
nous voyons les choses et le temps du
débat le temps de l'analyse qui va se se
prolonger jusqu'à la fin de l'année va
nous permettre d'avoir sur l'ensemble
des problématiques aéroportuaire d'avoir
des choix stratégiques que l'on pourra
développer ensuite damien quentin sur
l'aéroport l'opposent pas low cost alors
sur les records tout d'abord on voit
aujourd'hui la majorité socialiste qui
demande un audit dame du fait nous a dit
qu'elle avait travaillé depuis deux ans
avec monsieur patriat qu'elle avait
préparé cette transition sur la
bourgogne franche comté on arrive
aujourd'hui on est au mois de mai et on
demande encore un audit
donc c'est plus rien n'a été préparé sur
cet aéroport de dole la région ne
participe pas au financement
effectivement mais je pense qu'un outil
comme celui ci en franche comté on doit
on ne doit pas lui laisser de côté la
région de s'y intéresser participer
peut-être au financement apporté des
idées mémoire mais c'est pas vraiment ce
que nous avait dit sophie montel pendant
la campagne électorale elle voulait
privilégier un aéroport d'affaires à
dijon alors voilà on peut y venir à
l'aéroport
on peut le faire à dijon on peut aussi
le faire à dole on peut privilégier des
vols devant nationale a évolué sur cette
question en quelques mois alors on
évolue on apporte de nouvelles idées
tous les jours et le problème des vols
d'affaires c'est qu'à dole on arrive
vols d'affaires il n'y a pas de navette
vers l'est vers les gares comment
fait-on monsieur nono je vous demande
comment fait-on pour aller à la gare de
dole à la gare de besançon pour faire
des vols d'affaires ensuite des vols
d'affaires peut-être des personnes qui
voudraient aller en suis ensuite pendant
en suisse comment fait-on pour alan
suisse de lausanne
aujourd'hui la ligne de train c'est
c'est lamentable alors qu'on a voté des
partenariats avec la suisse il faut
vraiment mettre en place toute une
structure autour et cela passe aussi par
cet aéroport on peut laisser le low cost
parce qu'effectivement je pense que
c'est un socle avec des lignes
malheureusement de suppression vers
toulouse je pense que c'est ni
importante et développer l'aviation
d'affaires à côté oui parce qu on
précise qu'il ya une compagnie qui était
installée à dole qui vient de sortir est
de l'aéroport
cédric journaux qu'elle elle regarde la
fédération nationale des associations
d'usagers des transports sur ces
questions aéroportuaire sur les
aéroports
je pense qu'il est intéressant de
comparer avec ce qui se fait en europe
160 aéroports commerciaux en france 15
aéroports commerciaux en allemagne
posons-nous aujourd'hui la bonne
question est ce qu'il est judicieux
aujourd'hui de voir autant d'aéroports
en france mais quelque part ça c'était
un débat des places et un débat
politique c'est un choix des stratégies
politiques les différentes régions après
aujourd'hui supprimée l'aéroport de dole
puisque de toute façon peut-être que
l'audit déterminera qu'il n'y aura
peut-être pas suffisamment de besoin
tous les cas il est clair que si cet
aéroport venait à disparaître il est
plus qu'indispensable que les
bourguignons et franc-comtois aient la
possiblité de ces la possibilité de se
rendre sur des aéroports comme à roissy
comme bâle ou comme lyon parce
qu'aujourd'hui ces aéroports sont les
aéroports internationaux qui ont de
multiples destinations qui sont qui
permet d'un regard des cervelles depuis
notre
notre région ce rôle c'est de rejoindre
les aéroports en sont il n'y a pas de
liaison directe pour aller à lyon
saint-exupéry par exemple il faut cinq
heures en passant par paris c'est pareil
pour genève et c'est pareil pour bâle
notamment la suppression il serait
judicieux de voir avec la sncf ou
peut-être d'autres opérateurs
ferroviaires
quelles sont les possibilités pour
pouvoir créer d'autres trains sur roissy
aujourd'hui il n'y a qu'une maison train
entre besançon dijon roissy et line
peut-être qu'il serait judicieux d'en
créer plusieurs de la même façon sur
balles ou sur lyon saint-exupéry donc
pour vous la priorité c'est pas
forcément le maintien des aéroports en
bourgogne franche comté mais une d une
meilleure desserte des aéroports qui
entoure notre région tout dépendra des
résultats de l'audit a bien évidemment
si les besoins des bourguignons franc
comtois fait que ses besoins
tu as vraiment une réalité sur des
liaisons entre dole et d'autres villes
de france voire en dehors donc je pense
qu'il serait judicieux de garder ses
liaisons
mais force est de constater que
malheureusement etc 136000 140000 de
passagers par an principalement des gens
de côte-d'or du doubs du jura
les autres personnes de saône et loire
vont à lyon les personnes de l'yonne
vont vont à paris les personnes de
l'extrême est de du doubs vont à bâle
voilà la réalité elle est là aujourd'hui
après il ya un coup derrière ça je
laisserais monsieur neugnot et des
conseillers régionaux au débattre sur le
sujet connaissait l'union au delà de
l'aspect financier qui évidemment est
important est ce que la majorité
actuelle du conseil régional souhaite
garder un aéroport dans la grande région
nous nous avons des structures
aéroportuaires qui existe
l'audit vous voyez est nécessaire et je
le dis tout de suite que des
représentants de l'opposition ont
participé au comité de pilotage de cet
audit
parce que nous souhaitons qu'il y ait un
état partagé
voyez bien la question justement est-ce
qu'une relais à deux pas marre de nous
c'est quoi la vie ce dernier à
l'aéroport ces deux derniers ont l'air
d'avoir comme l'a dit monsieur journaux
une chaîne de mobilité qui nous permette
d'arriver et de partir de bourgogne
franche comté de façon la plus
rationnelle possible si on ne fait pas
une assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé
audit pour dire voilà le résultat que
l'on veut c'est pas ça la méthode c'est
de dire faisant l'état des lieux et
partageons avec l'été la conférence
nationale en fin de l'année
deschamps avec une décision en début
d'année prochaine de là va plusieurs
scenarii vont ressortir et on aura un
débat avec des collectivités avec les
usagers pour savoir comment on répond
cela et c'était très bien dit
la problématique des tgv est aussi en
cause la problématique des actionnaires
est en cause et c'est tout
l'intermodalité que la loi
notre nous permet maintenant de
maîtriser donc en attendant on laisse
payer le conseil général départemental
du genre mais ça n'aurait aucun remords
a laissé le conseil départemental du
virage et je n'ai pas dit ça ar mais je
n'ai pas dit ça géré je vous reprends
jeudi la position que nous avons eues a
été jusqu'à présent de dire nous ne
finançons pas le low cost
c'est ce que j'ai dit nous faisons un
état des lieux un audit des choix
stratégiques qui sont débattues avec la
population et on verra ce que cela donne
j'ai dit en dehors de tout est bloqué au
jus de toutes croyances voilà c'est cela
que nous mesdames on n'est qu'à fait pas
quand même le maintien du low cost avec
d'autres compagnies qui amènerait de nos
malheurs comme le disait john holmes
nous ne va rentrer un peu dans du détail
actuellement le parking est gratuit si
vous prenez 5 euros par passager pour le
parking vous amener des recettes est ce
que ryanair est d'accord pour cela
voilà il ya un certain nombre de points
y rentrer en négociation mais comme vous
l'avez dit de faire pour que pas vous
donner tout le détail
voilà donc je lui dis simplement que je
nous allons travailler le sujet nous
n'avons pas et on s'en excuse
la capacité d' expertise totale au sein
de nos services
donc nous faisons appel à des services
extérieurs indépendants pour nous aider
à la prise de décisions surtout à au
dialogue sur les territoires alors on
vous a dit de faire court parce qu'en
fait on a beaucoup de thèmes à aborder à
j'ai rêvé notamment les ter et les
trains on va passer oui au gros morceau
transport de du budget régional c'est
évidemment les trains avec les ter et
avec une annonce qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit
michel neugnot au tout début du mandat
marie-guite dufay tout juste élue
présidente a lors de son discours
d'investiture annoncé qu'elle souhaitait
mettre en place un ter gv et c'est à
dire de permettre aux abonnés thé vert
d'emprunter le tgv entre dijon et
besançon
sauf erreur de ma part ça n'avait pas
été annoncé pendant la campagne
électorale est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire en quoi consiste ce principe et à
quelle échéance il pourrait être mis en
place
rattner donc cela vous avez échappé mais
ça a été bien annoncer nous avons nous
avons nous sommes empreinte de
retravailler l'ensemble des dessertes
pour la nouvelle convention qui sera
signée auprès applique au 1er janvier
2018 dans la temps nous voulons
renforcer la liaison entre l'est et
l'ouest entre besançon et dijon et donc
les abonnés auront la capacité
d'utiliser avec leur carte d'abonnement
domicile travail ils auront la capacité
de monter dans des tgv en gare de
besançon viotte ou en gare de dijon pour
faire cette liaison cédé 1 à qui ça va
être mis en place au 1er septembre nous
avons voté le budget c'est une
contribution de la région en rythme
annuel 2 380 mille euros je vous ai vu
sourire cette région de canton il
apparaît je dirais que c'est
à la fois une bonne chose parce que les
liaisons entre dijon et besançon
aujourd'hui ne sont pas forcément les
mieux adaptés avec des heures creuses en
milieu de journée et un cadencement est
plus que nécessaire entre ces deux
villes parce que les services régionaux
que ce soit au service d'état à les
services des collectivités et ces termes
en sont répartis entre ces deux villes
et à terme c'est ce qui se fera de toute
façon pour le conseil régional parce que
je crois savoir qu'aujourd'hui et séries
sont pas encore complètement restructuré
en tous les cas il ya vraiment un réel
besoin entre ces deux villes et des
liaisons au demi heure voire à l'heure
aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas entre
besançon et dijon
or après derrière uni'sons grande
vitesse entre besançon viotte et dijon
ça implique il faut utiliser le tgv mais
avec une simple carte bourgogne liberté
qu'elle soit 20 - 26 ans au plus 26 ans
j'ai bien peur que l'on nous demande une
rallonge budgétaire on décale visage et
je peux répondre de la région avec
laquelle elle est réveillée par le
conseil régional il y aura une
contribution effectivement des usagers à
ce sujet mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que l'objectif est effectivement d'avoir
dans la desserte en 2018 mais c'est
demain le temps de la construis faut qu
on arrête ça au mois de juin
donc il y aura en heures pleines des
correspondances à la demi-heure en
alternant du direct ou semi directe est
due à l'homme du bus et puis en période
d'heure
creuse ça sonne alternance à l'heure est
donc renforcement des liaisons entre
besançon et dijon est ce que nous avons
voulu c'est avant parce que monsieur
journaux a totalement raison
les desserts qu'il faut les améliorer
donc nous avons cette possibilité du
pour certains usagers d'utiliser les
télés tgv qui sont qui permettent de
compléter l'offre
damien quant à honda et quand un parent
on a effectivement beaucoup de demandes
notamment d'internautes qui nous dit il
faut plus de thé vert entre dijon et
besançon c'est véronique qui nous disent
à ouali qui nous dit faut des ter plus
régulier et moins cher entre dijon et
besançon
est-ce que vous au front national vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne idée
cette tergv alors j'entends les grands
discours de monsieur neugnot notamment
sur l'aéroport fin de l'année début de
l'année prochaine
rien de précis je pense que les
téléspectateurs vous le dites ont besoin
de réponses précises
alors madame buffet nous a sorti le
tergv du chapeau le jour de la prise de
pouvoir
je n'avais jamais entendu parler avant
voilà pour peut-être essayer de
conquérir la côte d'or et les dijonnais
je pense que ça peut être quelque chose
de bien entre dijon et besançon en effet
beaucoup de personnes habitent dijon
travail ça allait mal à dire que c'est
bien quand même
on attend de voir quand cela va être mis
en place on voudrait une dame il exerça
landes 1er septembre monsieur 1er
septembre premier sommet jean hétu vous
voyez et croyez bien que pour la clique
et au 1er septembre il y a fallu que
l'on s'occupe du dossier un peu avant
parce que la production des freins à
l'adoption de ses skis c'est ce que nous
avons fait et nous faisons à notre
rythme donc le 1er septembre pour avoir
son pourrait effectivement prendre le
tgv entre dijon et besançon
s'il ya un abonnement bien sûr d'accord
parce que moi je voyage en seconde
classe missionné nos avec un abonnement
boyle un chauffeur mémo suis juillet sur
ceux du consulat jardin cette question
comment on peut être que satisfaits de
l'augmentation de la desserte c'est
clair on va pas on va pas faire de la
politique politicienne autres que des
spectateurs attendent autre chose de
nous néanmoins une chose est claire il
faut pas parce que cette ligne là pour
objectif aussi de matérialiser cette
fusion de régions
il ne faut pas réduire la question de la
desserte ter
la qui sauve cette nouvelle région à
dijon et besançon moi j ai du charolais
au milieu rural les questions à la
question des trains elle se pose et
dijon besançon tout le monde s'en moque
chez moi il ya des vraies questions qui
se posent on parle beaucoup de
paray-le-monial dix jours ses dimensions
nevers et c'est nancy battu dans mais ce
mandat précédent
paray-le-monial lyon qui va je pense
trouver un aboutissement partir de
l'année prochaine mais il ya des rêves
question qui se pose à la fois sur
l'infrastructure uni de l'évoquer mais
également sur la desserte et services
qui est rendu et là je pense qu'on a on
a des vrais des vraies améliorations
apportées on a aussi des vrais signaux
envoyés et des vrais signaux se devait
aussi de montrer que dijon et besançon
ça existe qui a une vraie relation à
matérialiser mais il faut aussi penser à
tout la desserte de la grande région
moi le premier quand je vais venir en
réunion à dijon et bientôt à besançon
puisque nous irons à ce prochain à
besançon
j'avoue que j'ai un petit peu de mal à
trouver des horreurs qui me permet de
faire l'aller retour dans la journée
c'est quand même un peu embêtant nos
téléspectateurs nous parle des liaisons
compliqué sur la ligne des hirondelles
sur avallon paris où il faut trois
heures ce new paris dit françoise les
trois quarts entre 1 et 3 buts comme en
2h 2h30 2h40 l'entrain et presque trois
heures en bus correspondance à auxerre
souvent selon l'heure et transgenres 40
alors que j'étais complètement est ce
que cette amélioration de la desserte
besançon dijon dijon besançon on va se
faire au détriment des officines dans la
région d vous me posez la question sur
le tergv je vous réponds tergv par
contre je reste de vue deuxième réponse
cours nous avons anticipé depuis 18 mois
entre la bourgogne la franche comté la
nouvelle desserte bourgogne franche
comté de 2018 avec tout au début une
analyse des habitudes de déplacements
domicile travail domicile études et
occasionnels par plaques territoriales à
l'intérieur de la bourgogne franche
comté
nous avons fait ensuite une analyse de
l'ensemble des dessertes existantes
intégrant la nouvelle compétence des
cars départementaux des transports
scolaires
et d'été ensuite nous nous sommes en
train de définir actuellement le cahier
des charges qui sera donnée sncf et qui
vise à augmenter la desserte globale en
km 1 alone en kilomètres on va jusqu'au
bout en kilomètres 1 de puciers % au
niveau 2 du territoire de l'ouest et au
niveau du territoire de l'est de la
bourgogne franche comté d'augmenter de
10% et ceci avec intérêts par la franche
comté il ya des styles et à l'ouest les
gourmets d'abord bal de l'hôtel montana
de l'accord google de la convention ter
franche-comté qui n'en font plus ni ses
directives et tous les territoires et
nelly à lui travaille sur
l'infrastructure qui est important quand
on parle de la liaison par et du mondial
la mûre lyon actuellement il y a ce mono
voir sous pour l'essentiel c'est des
lignes on roule à moins de 30 km heure
au s'est battu pour qu'au niveau du
contrat clos cela soit fait ça va être
fait on a lu avec nos homologues de
nombre net à l'époque la même démarche
donc c'est un dossier qui avance qui
avait très réalisable dans le contrat de
plan et c'est une bonne chose vous ne
m'a rappelé pour avoir une dormeuse par
les deux contractants avec la sncf on
nous avons vu les grilles plan état
région
je reviens voilà c'est autre chose on
nous a vendu la fusion des régions comme
permettant d'avoir plus de poids parce
que des régions plus grande pour
négocier ces conventions avec la sncf
est ce que ce sera le cas pour la
bourgogne franche comté vous aurez plus
de poids et plus de marge de manoeuvre
pour avoir plus de trains plus de
desserte pour les usagers et les gens
qui nourrirait vous dire c'est pourquoi
le vert le bon train au bon endroit et
un coût acceptable
c'est cela le challenge que nous avons
est effectivement
oui mais c'est une lapalissade c'est
pour que tout il faut que tout le monde
l'accès de ses dires le bon moyen de
transport n'est pas forcément partout le
train il ya le car il ya tous ceux qui
n'ont pas de cette co organisé deux cars
qui n'ont pas de ligne de train et tire
aussi des problèmes de mobilité
auxquelles il faut répondre parce que ça
va être le tournant par les regards
notre hôpital ce soit de la
complémentarité jeu que ce soit de
lassus presque ce soit de la
complémentarité non c'est que ans marc
chaput on peut faire un kilomètre et
demi que avec un vélo on peut faire 5 km
que si on prend le car et bien il une
dimension optimale pour le faire et le
trait plutôt un peu plus massifier et de
des distances un peuple on essaie c'est
le débat que nous allons avoir sur les
territoires avec les territoires et le
pour répondre à votre question
effectivement je pense que nous aurons
un poids en moins un poids plus
important que ce que l'on avait
séparément et aussi une interaction
personne ne sait que c'est la convention
sncf franche comté qui desservaient tout
l'est en partant de dijon et c'était pas
la convention bourgogne donc le fait
d'avoir une seule convention et avec une
complémentarité de vue va être essentiel
dans la démarche que nous avons avec les
jeunes c'est très important quelle base
est importante pour cette nouvelle
convention qui doit se négocier et qui
doit entrer en vigueur le 1er janvier
2010 et j'ai peur avec les propos de
monsieur neugnot quand il parle de
nouvelles dessertes au 1er janvier 2018
via la nouvelle convention thé vert
parce que derrière je sous-entend
suppression de liaisons ferroviaires sur
des petites lignes rural aujourd'hui des
liaisons qui servent les territoires qui
sont un petit peu abandonné quand même
je parle dans un autre étang sur arroux
par exemple donc en saône et loire qui
menace d'être supprimé je parle de la
ligne des hirondelles donc entre dole et
saint-claude donc très clairement
aujourd'hui j'ai peur j'ai peur que
demain on puisse effectivement augmenter
le nombre de trains et ça c'est tout à
fait louable entre paris auxerre donc
avec les liaisons de navetteurs entre
mâcon et lyon
tout autour de l'étoile de dijon et ça
c'est tout à fait louable aujourd'hui
n'a plus en plus de personnes qui vont
travailler tous ces grandes villes et
qui ont besoin de faire ses navettes
le matin le soir ça c'est tout à fait
louable que nous puissions avoir plus de
liaison avec à moindre coût par contre
ce ne doit pas se faire au détriment des
petites liaisons ferroviaires justement
une question sur une petite liaison
d'une internaute qui nous dit peut-on
honnêtement entretenir ligne comme celle
des hirondelles qui coûte très cher elle
coûte parce qu'on veut bien qu'elle
coûte et salle sncf la sncf sur sfr
réseau ces trois sites pas mobilité sncf
réseaux aix rff a émis un devis qui est
assez exorbitant pour refaire cette
ligne intégralement et je sais que le
futur de ces per actuel va donner 6
millions d'euros en état région
exactement 6 millions d'euros pour
refaire entre guillemets à minima cette
ligne de façon à ce qu'ils tiennent
jusqu'en 2020 mais quiz après 2001 et
aujourd'hui on ne peut que s'interroger
sur ces deux vie exorbitant des cncf
réseau quant à quentin robert va
demander à un membre du conseil
d'administration
la sncf réseau alors c'est tout nouveau
votre nomination mais je vous
connaissais la problématique alors déjà
éteints sur arroux il n'est pas question
de fermer
deuxièmement deuxièmement permet de
desserte ferroviaire en événements la
ligne des hirondelles
effectivement la présidente paris dit
buffet moi même son som arquebouté pour
que ce qui est prévu de rénovation dans
le cadre du contrat de plan se fasse
parce que pour qu'il y ait des larmes et
des misérables
non non non non non c'est vous allez
faire pour que les engagements qu'on
soit en une saison
mais c'est déjà bien passe pas ma
logique mais c'est déjà bien parce qu'il
y avait une tendance au niveau de sncf
réseau à dire on peut remettre ça sur le
ring et la ligne d horloger avec la
liaison suisse on a dit non
on a dit non on continue je précise pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas notamment
les téléspectateurs bourguignon il y en
a une qui dessert le haut-jura l'autre
le haut doubs
ah là il ya une raison si son niveau du
lac du loch et l'autre cette direction
de laon donc on est par contre la loi de
réforme et ferroviaires de 2014 donne la
possibilité aux régions de faire de
l'esprit de l'expérimentation et nous
nous pensons que n'est pas obligatoire
que cette ligne soit exploité par la
sncf a alors c'est à dire vous pourriez
l'exploiter moi même nous pourrions en
reprend la digestion et la confier à
d'autres opérateurs et nous allons
travailler sur ce sujet c'est une
demande aussi que nous faisons au niveau
de la r f l'association des régions de
france
l'association des régions de france se
dira avoir la possibilité pour certaines
y est bien de ne pas travailler avec
l'opérateur historique et dans le
travail et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'ouverture la concurrence où nous avons
un débat sur l'ouverture en 2019 ou non
est ce que ce sera 2026 nous sommes en
débat avec l'état sur ce point et nous
nous pensons que défendre la cncef
défense service public c'est aussi
parfois permettre l'ouverture et la
concurrence de certaines lignes la
capacité de l'expérimentation sur
certaines lignes parce que je vous
explique pourquoi c'est pas vrai même
idéologie d'avoir les charges structure
d'une grande maison comme la sncf sur
des lignes qui ont un très grand intérêt
local mais où le nombre de passagers est
relativement limitée et bien il ya
peut-être d'autres modèles économiques
comme pour les aéroports à trouver et ne
se ment d'as avec le mandat de
l'expérimentation ce avec le mandat de
l'innovation et dans ce sens nous
voulons aller toucher à la ligne des
hirondelles damien quant à gérald gordat
ont demandé la parole alors notre union
scellée slogan le bon remboursement mais
je devrais le rassurer et il n'y a
jamais le bon train bon moment est ce
que vous faites le dimanche soir avec
les étudiants sur la ligne laroche
migennes dijon les étudiants voyagent
entre les wagons de boue
il faut mettre ap voilà peut-être plus
de wagons chalon mâcon dijon dimanche
soir par et pour les étudiants vont
penser qu'elles montraient un bon petit
oignon vous perdez c'est ce qui vous
permettrait vous savez que le nombre de
wagons comme vous dites est liée à la
taille des quais et qu'on ne peut pas
aller au delà d'un certain nombre
d'autres encore faut-il avoir des
sillons sur des lignes qui sont quand
même les plus exploités de france
voilà donc à vous non je vous dis que
l'électrification l'électrification par
exemple de deux d'auxerre laroche peu
permettent plutôt d'avoir une traction
parmi d'autres d'une traction totalement
électrices qui nous permet de mettre des
trains plus capacitaire qui permettent
d'enlever il études que nous sommes en
train de faire sur la ligne paris dijon
lyon pour effectuer des hôpitaux des
actes monsieur donnio mais des actes
mais monsieur vous êtes jeune élu vous
actionnez le noble âge fort de son
savoir maîtriser dans la vive dans la
vie personnelle et dans la vie d'une
collectivité c'est gérer le temps c'est
gérer le temps et rassurez vous ce que
l'on va livrer mollo nivet ne pouvait
livrer au renouvellement du mandat au
renouvellement du mandat
j'espère et c'est notre volonté que en
matière de transport et d'intermodalité
la révolution aura plus être fait sur la
région bourgogne france-comté
l'enlisement dans l'intérêt des usagers
en partant des besoins des usages
impatience le saunier essentielle
là où je suis content je suis venu c'est
vous avez parlé de l'ouverture à la
concurrence en effet le 19 avril dernier
au parlement européen vos amis
socialistes ont voté le fantôme venir
rencontrer le quatrième paquet
ferroviaire
nous venons donc on va aujourd'hui ce
que vous pensez de la sncf et l'avenir
que vous lui réservez quatrième paquet
ont fait tourner la parole lors da sa
vous surprendre vous êtes nombreux
convertiront suis toujours impressionné
par la capitaine messine le new à nous
vendre l'invendable alors quand il parle
d'expérimentation évidemment on sait
tous que ça veut dire expérimentation de
danse d'une assemblée politique c'est
souvent quand on est on est dans le cas
de l'incapacité de pouvoir à pouvoir
gérer donc on trouve un moyen on trouve
un moyen d'essayer d'essayer de nous de
nous faire ben ils essayent ils essayent
après on verra si les occasions sont
satisfaits ce qui est sûr concernant la
ligne des hirondelles on en a parlé tout
à l'heure c'est qu'il ya un mot de la
trouvais ça on est d'accord maintenant
l'aveu d'impuissance que que vous venez
de faire le vis-à-vis de la sncf
vis-à-vis de la sncf puisque en dix ans
une classe d'écart au timbre est un
véritable aveu d'impuissance est pas
prêt de gestion de la sncf c'est un
problème de charges de structure qui
s'appliquent sur des lignes et on a des
exemples honnête des exemples en écosse
au nahd exemple en suède en norvège où
effectivement des lignes qui parle par
hectare est stocké historique ne
trouvaient pas leur équilibre économique
quand elle jeté gérer différemment on
arrive à retrouver leur narcissisme en
bandana parole varial des conséquences
une norme sociale
si si si j'aimerais vous faire réagir
parce que c'est assez cocasse on a eu
une question en début de semaine sur
justement ce thème l'agent lui qui vous
demandaient pourquoi la région ne crée t
elle pas un opérateur ferroviaire sous
forme de sem société d'économie mixte
pour exploiter elle-même des liaisons
tgv nous avons des technicentres nous
fabriquons des rames dans cette région
nous pourrions ainsi aller à paris à bon
prix et ailleurs aussi en contrôlant les
coûts devenu délirant de la sncf qui
veut répondre à ce ce constat question
ça vous semble une bonne idée est ce que
c'est réaliste sur monsieur usagers
l'heure c'est pas très réaliste sur les
tgv parce qu'aujourd'hui les tgv sont
des liaisons nationales c'est l'outil
commerciaux la sncf l'ouverture à la
concurrence des tgv ne se fera pas avant
2019 2020
voilà après il n'empêche que
l'expérimentation est tout à fait
possible est celle règlement européen le
permet de 2007 d'expérimenter sur un
certain nombre de lignes soit sous forme
de société d'économie mixte soit sous
forme de régie soit sous forme de
délégation de service public bref ça
c'est les formes administrative que je
ne ris pas autant comment favorable bien
sûr nous sommes favorables à la
condition qu'il y ait un maintien voire
qu'il y ait même une augmentation de
l'offre pour pouvoir répondre aux
attentes des usagers locaux
donc là voulaient clairement banco pour
la ligne des hirondelles par exemple ce
que propose monsieur gagnon je dirais
qu'ils cela mérite quand même une
réflexion avant de d'avoir un avis plus
que positif excusez moi mais on n'a pas
parlé des moyens pour pour pour la
100ème modèles comme ça je vais vous
dire un certain nombre de choses répond
précisément à votre question est ce que
vous savez que on peut gagner énormément
avec une production différente de la
part de l'opérateur
est ce que vous savez que l'on peut
renforcer les liaisons dont on a parlé
besançon dijon avec un autre modèle
d'organisation déroulement différents et
un coût moindre
il faut savoir que nous sommes dans une
révolution des transports actuellement
et que gérer différents n'a pas encore
fait nos tenues de la régionalisation
des marais normal oui il ya une démarche
qui est impossible par contre sur
certains sur certains secteurs
les charges de structure que l'on
applique sur des parties de ligne donnée
plomb d'entrée dieu donc nécessité de
trouver un autre modèle économique et
c'est ce que l'on peut faire en
territoire et ont intérêt on a bien
compris on termine à ibou sur les
terreurs s'il ya d'autres questions sur
le sérieux des monsieur le manioc on a
un vrai problème a400m de qualité de
l'offre il faut se dire on a un vrai
problème est qu'en dise devra qui devra
en qui devra dans le cadre du dans le
cas de la nouvelle convention être
réglés
notamment une certaine une problématique
sur les pénalités on sait que les
pénalités ne soient proportionnels au
nombre de trajets un exemple en france
comptait en 2014 7 % des trains
supprimés pour des raisons de grève de
la tempérer de problèmes matériels et
seulement six cent cinquante mille euros
de pénalité sur un budget de 90 millions
est pire que ça c'est que sur les les
trains qui restent y en a 8 il ya vu
pour cent et demi de problèmes de
ponctualité et tenez vous bien que 8000
euros 8000 euros de pénalités 8000 euros
de pénalité soit 90 dollars voire d
après difficulté ne souhaite pas pour le
dire parce que je veux pas être prise à
défaut
des travaux conséquents vont avoir lieu
sur les villes de rénovation le pix avec
2018 donc en même temps les usa ne
s'attende à l'armée en même temps que
c'est une des sociétés pour avoir la
robustesse des lignes parce que pendant
40 ans n'a rien fait sur les lignes
pendant 40 ans n'a rien fait il ya eu
énormément c'est jallet monsieur ya eu
énormément de travaux sur notamment l'
axe dijon besançon avec des retards
conséquents grands médias nan mais vous
allez accru de rio le sait très bien
comment on va pouvoir gérer cette
période là où ça va être en matière de
report sur d'autres modes de transport
catastrophique ça va être catastrophique
on le sait je le dis maintenant et
d'autre part un dernier chiffre vous
avez vous donné par rapport à celles ci
ont conçu l'entretien du réseau sur
l'entretien du réseau et non pas les
nouvelles lignes
la contribution de l'état est descendu à
31%
tout gouvernement confondus en
angleterre on dit thatcher et où la
contribution de l'état sur le réseau et
de 62%
cherchez l'erreur l'une des explications
des coûts ils sont imputés par la sncf
viennent de cela parce que pato n'a fait
rff ou nas une entreprise avec des
dettes
son capital est loin seulement la laide
mais on vit avec ça et ça ne leur
fallait une ville avec ça un dernier mot
sur le ferroviaire à propos du tgv
notamment dit et j'ai l'époque le fameux
paris orléans clermont lyon qui doit en
fait c'est là
votre ligne paris lyon mais qui
passerait par le centre aujourd'hui un
appel à une association pour abandonner
ce projet pour favoriser les lignes
existantes notamment paris clermont et
puis par contre on a des questions
beaucoup de questions d'internautes qui
nous demandent à quand ce fameux tgv
nevers paris vous quelle est votre
position les usagers ont construit cette
ligne où on favorise plutôt les liaisons
liste la construction de la ligne pau
khl a un intérêt ici à moyen terme à
long terme je dirais 2030 2040
dans un premier temps il l'est beaucoup
plus judicieux de réinvestir sur la
liaison paris nevers en particulier avec
une rénovation des voies pour pouvoir
permettre certaines sections à 200
kilomètres/heure qui n'existe pas encore
actuellement et gagné environ 10 minutes
entre paris et clermont-ferrand et ça je
pense que c'est la priorité à la fois de
l'état mais également la région puisque
de toute façon les trains d'équilibré du
territoire qui font actuellement paris
nevers à terme d'ici un an deux ans je
ne sais pas si l'état les subventionnera
encore donc dans le coup il faudra pas
le supprimer environ 12 de nouveau
beaucoup de navetteurs sur cette ligne
là les supprimer ça serait quand même
pas du tout la droite pour revenir à la
ligne pau khl la ligne pau classes ont
intérêt également parce qu'elle permet
de desservir des territoires qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas desservis par
tgv et en particulier je pense au sud
nivernais je pense au massif central et
qui mérite aussi d'avoir une liaison
rapide vers paris mais elle ne doit pas
se faire au détriment la ligne classique
et de larry nevers clermont ferrand en
asie mais ce sur cette ligne non
effectivement je rejoins votre position
la question du tgv finalement elle se
pose parce qu'est saturation de la
première ligne
elle s'oppose premièrement pour ces
raisons-là la pose et la possibilité on
a vu dans le débat public avait été
doublé la ligne existante entre paris et
lyon n'avait pas d'intérêt en terme en
termes d'aménagement du territoire
donc on ne peut que soutenir cette
initiative maintenant 2040 c'est loin
effectivement son abandonne aujourd'hui
la ligne la ligne
la ligne actuelle d'ici 2040 en espérant
hypothétiquement que tgv arrive ce sera
catastrophique pour la desserte de la
nièvre effectivement du massif central
la position du conseil régional si à
l'aise gb rhin rhône actuellement ou une
partie c'est parce qu'en 90 92 on a
commencé d'en parler donc il ya des
études qui sont qui se poursuivent
la région bourgogne france-comté les
finances par contre dans un temps plus
rapprochés nous sommes en train de
travailler sur la continuité de la lgv
rhin rhône avec la possibilité de
l'interconnexion lgv ter au niveau de la
gare montchanin le creusot et nous
sommes là dans un temps plus court a
essayé de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
travailler sur ce sujet avec des fonds
européens parce qu'il ya des problèmes
d'équilibré de rentabilité de cette
ligne donc on est il faut travailler à
la fois pour le long terme
2040 peut-être je sais que ce poc est la
première ligne lgv d'après le rapport
durant l'été fait qu'ils repartiraient
donc c'est celle où il faut y aller et
l'yonne une honte a terminé
c'est notamment les 35 km qui montrent
qu'entre petit roi et le tueur bart
mulhouse qui doit permettre aussi à
l'extrême est de laquelle nous avons
abandonné la partie entre genlis à dijon
qui sait gagner deux minutes en matière
de desserte n'avait pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pour 330 millions et reporter
ça sur l'interconnexion que l'on veut à
chagny montchanin et nous avons
l'électrification entre chagny et
montchanin qui doit permettre de
réaliser ça pour l'adf ce sens par les
grands santé comme comme cela on y fera
me il faut voir sur le long terme les
études mais là on est comme me l'a dit
monsieur le surintendant 2040
aujourd'hui je pense que les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent ont
besoin de deux choses précises sur
certaines lignes à grande vitesse
forcément l'aura compris bien sûr
forcément faut mettre le tout sans place
le programme en place mais aujourd'hui
je pense qu'ils ont plus besoin de
réponses précises sur des lignes ter
notamment entre le nivernais
et dijon je pense que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui les touche le plus nevers
dijon et et à m'améliorer
quand je parle de nevers je pars de la
nièvre tout entière est juste on
n'abandonne pas ce territoire c'est pour
moi ce sont les priorités du conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté a
abandonné personne dans cette grande
région et que monsieur news voilà on a
beaucoup de questions autour de ça on va
parler intermodalité ça va me faire
plaisir parce que on a parlé de la vie
on a parlé du temps on va parler des
autocars puisque leur maintenant les
régions la compétence 1 ou l'auront en
deux courants 2010 est pour le transport
à dire interurbain hors urbain en tout
cas donc le ce qu'on connaissait les
transco l'écart dans le jura etc etc
mais d'abord on voit aussi apparaître
depuis quelques mois avec la loi macron
des lignes de bus qui sont désormais
ouvertes
on a vu à dijon à besançon argus fixe du
que ce mega bus etc
mais c'est surtout des liaisons en fait
qui existe déjà par le faire or hier un
vers paris et crs que ce sont des choses
qui vous conviennent je veux d'abord
posé la question à monsieur journaux qui
représente les visages et la scène soit
suffisant personnes toujours défendu une
complémentarité des modes donc entre
cars et trains mais pas une concurrence
entre mode
nous défendons une concurrence à
l'intérieur du mode saas est une réalité
aujourd'hui la scène s'être coûte
environ 20 30% plus cher qu'un autre
opérateur ferroviaire vis-à-vis de la
concurrence du karma kron la bourgogne
franche comté est concerné puisque nous
avons de nombreux visages les maisons en
particulier paris auxerre chalon lyon
qui concurrencent frontalement le thé
vert entre paris auxerre qui
concurrencent frontalement cette liaison
parce que cette liaison s'est dégradé de
plus en plus tous les soirs environ
trois soirs sur cinq de semaine le train
18h31 au départ de paris vers site en
retard à l'arrivée à linge au moins cinq
minutes de retard et ça ce n'est plus
acceptable aujourd'hui ce qui n'est plus
acceptable non plus c'est de voir des
tarifs qui peuvent être exorbitant
lorsque nous sommes un usager
ponctuelles que nous n'avons pas de
quart de réduction
et ça c'est une réalité aujourd'hui un
billet train pour faire dijon paris en
thé vert voire en tgv
c'est cher aujourd'hui c'est cher pour
l'usager alors bien évidemment écart
macron ont utilisé ce créneau se dire
voilà nous proposons des offres beaucoup
beaucoup moins cher certes avec un temps
de trajet qui est doublée voire triplée
est ce qu'il faut aussi mettre en
évidence et qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des
produits d'appel sur fait car macron un
paris dijon 1 euros 5 euros c'est un
produit d'appel ça ne durera pas ça ne
durera pas et je dirais même que les
cinq ou six opérateurs qui gravitent en
france aujourd'hui
prenons l'exemple de l'allemagne
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus que deux ou
trois opérateurs dont finalement la
concurrence à terme les histoires a
beaucoup moins mais ce que ça pourrait
être un moyen de compléter les circuits
existants et notamment les navettes ter
qui existent dont il n'existe pas
justement entre certaines villes ne
confondons pas les quarts macron qui ont
un intérêt commercial pour une
entreprise privée et rend ses propres
risques
une entreprise qui veut créer une
liaison entre nevers dijon va prendre
ses propres risques
donc elle ne sera pas du tout
subventionné par le conseil régional
contrairement à une liaison
complémentaires par cars qui est
diligentée par le conseil régional qui
elle sera subventionné à plus ou moins
grande échelle mais qui sera en
complémentarité
c'est bien là où l'intermodalité un
terme et ainsi que de toute évidence le
réseau my ferroviaire doit rester
vraiment l' architecture de base sur
lequel les bus voire même les vélos puis
se greffer pour aller récupérer un train
aller sur paris elle sur dijon elle est
sur nos verts sur auxerre ben voilà
c'est ringard n'a effectivement le
problème des débuts seront déduits on
prendrait autres jours parce qu'ils
avaient grève de la sncf donc j'ai testé
pour ça fonctionne pour relier nevers à
paris pour ouvrir et c'est vrai que bon
ça fonctionne effectivement j'ai plus de
trois heures je crois que c'était japon
d'autre part d'autres stimulants après
en train n'avait pas d'autres
possibilités donc s'est récemment marié
en france et qu'on entend 1h57
incroyable mais le problème prometic
était pas là n'y avait pas d'autre
solution donc j'ai un quart un cas
exceptionnel et ce que j'ai pu
comprendre à l'intérieur notamment et
que les gens qui étaient dans le bus
c'est que c'est principalement des gens
qui ne peut payer le prix le prix d'un
billet pour voyager
et c'est vrai que l'écart il faut
aujourd'hui nevers paris je ne sais pas
combien c'est un aller retour mais sa
bête au moins soixante dix 70 0 81 08
donc donc aujourd'hui un aller retour en
bus je vous a coûté combien je suis plus
de témoins quinzaine d'euros trop de
mémoire c'était juste un aller mais
quelle est la cohérence on a
l'impression que le gouvernement
autorise des bus qui ont directement en
concurrence avec les ter financé par
l'argent public des concurrence puisque
la wii bleue serait michel neugnot le le
loisir de couleurs le corps évitiez mais
parfois tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est tout si effectivement sa soeur a
tendance à faire concurrence aux
dessertes ferroviaires on n'arrivera
jamais à trouver des bus macron dans les
zones qui sont pas desservis par les
traits puisqu'il sienne ne sont pas
desservies par les trains c'est
justement sauf contrainte technique
c'est principalement parce qu'il n'y a
pas assez de monde pour pouvoir
rentabiliser une desserte par train donc
les bus ne viendront pas ici donc c'est
une vraie une vraie problématique et je
pense qu'une chaîne own you nous en
parlera maintenant il ya quand même une
question qui se pose encore sarah
compris envers cela est pour ou contre
les bus macro jusqu'à présent le bal le
problème pour ou contre j'ai pas trop
d'avis à donner ce vraiment ce que je
constate qu'on le doit ce que je
constate c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est en
train de faire concurrence parce
qu'effectivement gains après en termes
de prix pour tout ce qui peut permettre
texte d'améliorer la desserte pour les
habitants était de rendre le voyage plus
ou moins coûteux pour moi c'est une
bonne une bonne une bonne initiative
maintenant si c'est à l'encontre
effectivement de ce que fait la sncf et
la région
pour moi c'est dommageable mais il ya
peut-être un système à trouver avec un
certain nombre certain nombre de
cohérence à mettre en place pour
l'instant ça n'existe pas avant michel
deniau adamian quand tu as attribué
mais sur ces bus bien sûr on moi je les
ai pris aussi comme monsieur gorda on
voit bien que par exemple sur pour faire
de dijon paris les personnes qui
prennent ce buste et des personnes qui
n'ont pas envie de payer le prix fort de
la sncf où tu ne peuvent pas aussi on
peut le dire c'est ils ne peuvent plus
prendre le train aujourd'hui on peut
plus se déplacer c'est devenu beaucoup
trop cher après le problème c'est que
voilà on est en face nos propres thébert
con qu'on paye avec la région qu'on
subventionne
des bus qui nous font une concurrence
déloyale messieurs nonu et contre le low
cost mais là je crois qu'on est dans le
low cost parce que j'ai payé 30 euros
pour faire l'aller-retour dijon paris en
bus alors que normalement c'est 140
euros contre 1 donc je pense qu'une
grande partie compensé le rc parce que
on va laisser répondre mais on a du mal
à voir la cohérence c'est car mâcon
c'est une décision gouvernementale de
les mettre en place une régulation qui
est fait par l'art à faire une
association structure de doit réguler
transport et de donner des avis
d'opportunités nous sommes consultés la
région donne son avis sur les clés
concerne 2 kg à moins de 200 km il y a
si on prend la réalité des choses
il y à des liaisons qui ne se font pas
actuellement je pense ya un karma
conquis c'est dijon lons le saunier où
on a pas d'offres actuellement donc là
pour nous est ton objectif c'est la
dernière fois nous avons été consultés
sur du dijon besançon belfort la réalité
qui est actuellement dans un sens ça
complète l'offre dans l'autre sens la
concurrence eurent donc sonné mais des
avis et après donc à par exemple vous
avez donné un avis négatif
on a donné un avis c'est un dossier très
complet très complexe qui est à donner
on dit voilà l'impact que cela va avoir
dans un sens et menée contre
par contre les lisons dans l'autre sens
voilà il ya un impact qui nous gêne
moins et le bus roulent aujourd'hui
parce que il y a débuté son lion fragon
et qui desservent les villes que vous
venez de décrire 16h d'eau que par
contre parce que j'aurais bien dire
c'est que l'objectif parce qu'on était
parti de nouvelles compétences des
régions
nouria la volonté sans y revient alors
on y revient alors j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure alors venez vite fait donc ce
qu'on avance il nous reste la vie d'une
ruche c'est d'avoir
un réseau de transport régional unique
avec notre propre politique de vente de
marketing ce qui est une chose nouvelle
et pour cela il faut que l'on ait la
liberté tarifaire qui est prévu dans la
loi mais cap était de donner totalement
nous avons la liberté tarifaire sur les
voyageurs occasionnels
nous n'avons pas la liberté tarifaire
sur le mifi de travail nous n'avons pas
la liberté s'arrêtèrent ce domicile
victimes et nous demandons au niveau de
la r f
la possibilité au gouvernement de
prendre le décret qui est prévue pour la
loi pourquoi les pourquoi je dis ça
parce que effectivement augmenté et il
commet pour augmenter non c'est pas pour
ça
s'il faut travailler on voit bien que
honey on n'est plus dans le transport
conçu il ya il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans
voire même cinq ans il faut de la
réactivité
il faut des produits avec des tarifs
précis qui soit compréhensible
il faut une pas des couples produits
marché sur certaines lignes qui sont
différentes pour s'adapter aux
circonstances pour s'adapter au public
faire de la concurrence aux carmes à
caen est possible on a des trains qu'ils
ne sont pas bondée on peut très bien
faire avec les nouvelles moyenne d'un
billettique des possibilités pour une
offre 40 places à allaoui à prix cassés
ce que fait la sncf elle le fait pour le
tgv le fait pour nous et nous autorités
organisatrices de transport nous n'avons
pas la capacité de le faire
ce que la loi a changé en nous donnant
cette autorité de véritables a ôté c'est
d'avoir la capacité de définir nos
produits de définir les prix et en
partant des besoins des usagers et les
besoins des usagers sont différents
suivant les lieux suivants le temps de
transport qu'ils veulent acquérir et on
veut aussi avoir un système de
billettique unique qui soit transparent
pour l'usager actuellement vous prenez
en garde un oeil vers internet et vous
donnera les crimes du territoire à des
sites du territoire vous n'avez pas la
même tarification qu'un train ter
la couleur du taxi n'est pas la même et
le prix n'est pas le même alors que ce
sont les mêmes matériels qui sont les
transports de même qualité dans les
mêmes temps donc on voit bien connaître
dans une révolution des transports il
faut intégrer aussi les nouvelles
technologies les nouvelles technologies
qui vont transformer totalement says je
pense notamment à tous les territoires
parce que quand on parle à terme dalit
et qui les territoires qui n'ont pas de
train qui n'ont pas de cas et où il va
devoir innover expérimentée elle n'en
savait que nous avons parlé dans la
deuxième partie puisque effectivement
les réseaux départementaux maintenant
seront de votre ressort mais pour
l'instant il est presque midi on va
prendre connaissance de l'actualité en
bourgogne et en franche comté et on se
retrouve donc dans quelques minutes à
tout de suite